The Joe Rogan experience.
There's always been that situation too. We have these really hungry,
talented artists,
and they get taken advantage of by whether it's executives or who,
whoever is the money,
people that figure out how to lock these people into some long-term contract,
where the lion's share of all their work and creativity is going to be
enjoyed by the company and not by the artists themselves. You always have these.
That part of the models. I mean,
hopefully there's enough pie to go around and everybody is kind of okay with
that. I mean, there's a certain number you get to,
we probably don't care anymore how much they're making,
because you're making so much also, you know, but, uh,
but that model that's, that's not a mystery,
especially if you're coming up the times I, when I came up,
like we already knew all of that is if you got,
if you got locked into a bad record contract where somebody screwed you over,
like it's kind of on you a little bit. It wasn't like it's not the fifties,
the sixties where like we stepped into things and didn't know, uh,
and it has nothing with my background. I never got screwed over though.
The worst people I've ever met in this business were in the bands.
They were not, they were not the labels because you know who they are,
you know what they're doing. They don't really change. You're not going to be,
you'll be fooled. You know,
it's the people that you have camaraderie with that you think are in the,
in the trenches with you, that you find out like those,
that people let you down more than you get hoodwinked by the business.
People you there's no secret what they're doing. Have you been.
You've been hoodwinked by other artists.
Everybody has. Yeah. I just, I'm not, I'm not making a point about artists are.
I'm just saying that the big, bad record business, like not for me, not my days,
I've worked some great people, you know, some really supportive, uh, um,
positive people. Who've been great part of my career. You know,
I actually can't, I can only name, like I can name 30 years,
maybe like one or two people that came across who I hope I never see it again in
that end of the business. Otherwise, like that's a pretty good ratio.
That is a very good ratio.
So essentially there's always going to be people that take advantage of people
that don't really understand or too eager and accept a bad contract.
Yeah. But there's no excuses for not reading that.
We're just too far along like this. It shouldn't be that easy to focus on today.
I've been offered a lot of bad contracts, but I didn't sign them either.
You know?
And I've been in situations where I've looked at a contract and it's,
that's the nature of most business. He has a,
someone's going to be better than somebody else. Right.
So when you look at that and you realize,
it looks like you are no matter what going to do that,
this isn't a good situation. Like it's,
I don't take that as like a personal attack or like, okay, well,
this isn't good for me. It's not good. I'll go find somewhere else to do this.
They're just establishing rules for the game for you.
There's no connect. Yeah. But they're in, they're in business. Right. You know,
it's like, again, prince, what was his, uh, what did he say? He.
Owned his name. Right?
I think it was something, uh, that I'm going to get the quote wrong.
But somewhere around the time where he changed his,
just the symbol and they said something about, somebody said something to too,
about the record business. He said, no, I'm not in the record business.
You're in the record business. I make music, you know? And that's,
that's kind of, it it's that it's true, but they're not, there's no,
there's no similarities to them.
There's no reason that you're a great talent that you should also have a great
understanding of the business side of things.
They're not really interconnected for most people,
but we are far enough along now.
We're hopefully you have somebody with you and things were more transparent that
you shouldn't get locked into these horrible deals anymore.
Do you remember when Courtney love wrote that piece where she was
explaining the music?
I think it was in spin magazine where she was explaining the music business in
terms of like where the money goes and how they over artists.
Do you remember that?
I don't remember that, but then don't get in the music business. That's not new.
I mean, it's not, is that a revelation? Do you, did you read that?
And we're like, wow. Like.
It was shocking to me because I'm not in the music business. So to me,
I was like, wow. So that's how they do it. Yeah. I was, I was confused.
Like when it, when it.
Know, if you're a band, people bands don't do this anymore.
If your band sells 2 million records,
everybody in that band is probably making a lot of money buying houses. Right.
And that CD cost $18. Like you're making your money. You're pretty happy.
It's only down the road where someone says, okay, you guys, you did buy a house.
Did you see how much they made?
And you are shocked for a second to realize you take that seating divided up
between yourselves, your band and what the record they make a lot more than you.
That's why they're in the record business. That's, what's, they're, you know,
some of them are too smart to be in the bands.
Or not smart.
Enough. Well, it depends on what, what you can handle. If you can hit,
I couldn't handle that kind of last time myself. I don't, I don't want, I I'm,
I, I invent things that nothing,
I don't want to be somebody who I have that my whole livelihood is reactionary
to other people creating something that I can now work with.
I want to make it from scratch.
Yeah. That's a weird situation to be in relying upon other people's creativity.
Yeah.
Yeah. And, but, you know,
you can do that when you don't have a com you don't have a,
a creative bone in your body. Some people are really good at numbers and math.
Some people are really creative, you know, and if you recognize really on, well,
I would like to be, I mean,
that's a lot of the great people who work outside of bands once wanted to be in
a band, but realized like, I don't have it. I love music,
but I want to be a part of it. Anyway.
I want to help someone else do great things, you know, but I,
I'm not the guy to be in the band or the girl, you know.
Uh, have your own music and you own your music. What does,
what does a record label do for you in 2021?
Well, what do you mean if you own your own music?
If you create your own music, right? If you say you hire.
Able to do for you,
they have money that you don't have to promote and spend and put you on tour.
You know, young bands need, they can't, you know, van or no van,
it costs money to tour a lot, you know? So, so.
That's something that simply loan you the money.
That's what, that's how they can be good for a young band really, or any band,
any, you know, it's like, otherwise you don't have the tools,
the assets to get your music in lots of places. I mean,
there's more opportunities with social media, of course. And it's, you know,
look, the good news is anybody can do it now.
And the band is anybody can do it now just because it's crowded.
And there's just like, it's hard to know what anybody's up to, you know,
but the record labels, they can still have a great, they have a great purpose.
Of course, you know, there is some people say their banks,
they're just funding your trip. And you have,
you have a big bill at the end and they have.
A connection to streaming services.
And they have all those contacts that you, uh, that you wouldn't have on your.
Now when a person is like savior a new band and you get signed by a record
company, how does someone find out about you? I mean,
what is the primary way they find out about you? If it's not the radio,
which had always used to be,
did they find out about you through streaming services? Like,
are there channels that are sponsored that people get excited about?
Because they know that this channels where new interesting music gets broken.
We're both going to do some homework, going to do some homework after this.
And if I find out I'll let you know. I mean, really that's the, well,
that's the question. I don't know. I mean, because there's,
it's just jammed up everywhere, you know?
So a lot of great things about the way things work now,
the models that we had before were really effective too.
And at least you could put yourself on a path that if you did X, Y, and Z,
maybe your band would get a shot, you know, play your clubs, get your download,
taped together. Maybe a rec company wants to work with you.
And then they're gonna give you some money to practice. You know,
you make that record, you make a video and you go,
and they give you some money to go on tour.
Like this was a path to maybe be in a band that was successful.
So you take that away. You know, it is just every man,
every man woman for themselves, just, you know,
trying to find a way to quote unquote, kind of get lucky.
If you're an establish act, you got up, you got opportunities.
If you're doing it the other way, you're just, it's really,
everybody's trying to get lucky. And then by the end,
when someone sees what that person did by the time you figured out it's too late
there, it's got to do something else, everyone. That's what it is. I mean,
as far as I know, you know, but I'm also not brand new.
Like if I was 21 years old, I'd probably understand this better than I do. Um,
you know, I, the way I came up was just a different, I mean,
it was just a different model and that's okay. That a lot of that's gone.
I mean, it's changed so drastically. I mean, you remember in the late nineties,
maybe, you know what the diamond award was? No,
that's when they had to invent it, it was, you know,
the gold record platinum record. It wasn't enough.
People are going like 12 times platinum. So they invented the diamond award,
which was 10 million. Whoa. The diamond award. Yeah.
That's how much money was going around in those days before the internet,
really.
People buy CDs today. They still sell.
I don't know where you buy one online, I guess, I guess. Yeah. I mean,
I mean, I guess we're going to play it. I mean, let's find that laptops,
aren't going to have hard drives more than.
These right now, but am I going to break down real quick? That's interesting.
What.
Is it for sure? No, no, actually flopped. They don't, it was for awhile,
like a bonus.
If your company wants to spend some money to make vinyl with you now,
it's kind of like, you can throw in CDs, but the production of that is like,
yeah, yeah. It's the cardboard you put around it. It's cool.
To have vinyl. Yeah. These don't, they don't seem cool.
I mean, streaming is one thing. Let me see. These are, oh.
Wow. Streaming's 83% of music industry venue. Wow.
What is.
That's the getting your songs in TV and in commercials and.
The licenses. So that's 2% physical,
9% is a physical. So that's live performances.
Physical is a combination of CDs and LPs and.
Oh, physical things. Oh, I get it. And then digital downloads are 6%.
So physical copies are just, yeah.
Taking up the bulk of that pie right there.
Streaming takes up the bulk of the pie. So yeah. Oh, interesting.
So CDs and it's kind of a.
What is happening in 2020? It says what, uh.
It's more vinyl than it is a CD and other.
Physical, the green and the blue that's OCD.
The green is vinyl, which is the largest.
Vinyl's not like blowing up. Anybody tells you it's back.
It's not like it's not, you know,
not by kissed written that the kiss records in those days. It's just,
it's a boutique-y kind of thing. It's cool.
Catch new episodes of the Joe Rogan experience for free. Only on Spotify.
Watch back catalog J R E videos on Spotify,
including clips easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on Spotify.
You can listen to the JRE in the background while using other apps and can
download episodes to save on data costs. All for free.
Spotify is absolutely free.
You don't have to have a premium account to watch new JRE episodes.
You just need to search for the JRE on your Spotify app.
Go to Spotify now to get this full episode of the Joe Rogan expenses.